And everybody this is Dr. Cutters, this is point number three in our work through to untangle this physiological web.
This one we're going to talk about lifestyle considerations. This is really going to be a short video.
There's not a whole lot new stuff in this.
So we talk about lifestyle considerations. What can we do differently?
And I'm not going to pull up all the studies on this. But there is like a zillion studies unstressed and autoimmune disease.
Stress increases inflammation of the brain. Stress down regulates the parasympathetic nervous system.
It up regulates the sympathetic nervous system. Your parasympathetics affect your ability to detoxify, ability to get rid of inflammatory markers.
Oxidative stress goes up with stress. You know increase NFCAPABADA, increase TH17 response.
It's just not a good thing. There's nothing that comes good out of stress except for you to exit a difficult situation quickly.
That's what the whole response of the sympathetic nervous system of the stress response is all about.
It's for you to run away from your stressor or for you to fight that stressor or you to respond adequately to that stressor.
The problem is we live in a world where we're supposed to just kind of suck it up and deal with stress that's part of life.
Well, it is part of life, but you need to learn how to deal with this and get rid of these things.
You need to exit a stressful situation the best way you possibly can.
So, we can't always quit our job. We can't always leave every relationship.
Kids cause stress in our life. All sorts of things cause stress that can't make go away.
Think of things like adaptogens. Adaptogenic herbs can be very helpful.
We have multiple adaptogenic blends on our store and the reason why we have so many blends is because some people respond differently to different blends.
So, they tend to have a synergistic effect with one another.
So, you know, really it's a trial and error with adaptogens.
There isn't just here. This is the adaptogen for thyroid.
This is the adaptogen for autoimmune disease. It just doesn't work that way.
Every human being is different.
So, adaptogens help balance your horrible response.
Help balance your stress response can decrease cortisol.
Help balance cortisol. That can be really huge.
CBD has been effective for this too. So, consider using CBD.
THC can be effective with this as well, but that's illegal everywhere.
And that can have negative effects on some people too, but CBD is pretty safe.
It's legal everywhere. That's something you should consider.
And obviously making better choices and just different choices and trying to get outside and ground yourself and enjoy the wilderness.
So, that can be a huge stress relief activity right there.
So, the next thing is sleep. Sleep is very overlooked.
I remember years ago being a part of a group where I remember the teacher, the group was coming with sleep, was overrated.
You need to try to get as much done as you can do.
Well, study after study after study dispute that you need to get your sleep.
If you're not getting your sleep, you're not healing.
I have a couple of videos on the way your brain cleanses itself is through sleep.
During a sleep pattern, your glial cells actually contract.
That's how your glimphatic system, it's called your glimphatic system.
Your glial and phatic system work in just cleansing the brain.
When you don't sleep, your brain inflammation goes up period.
So, your brain inflammation goes up, your overall body inflammation goes up.
You're going to, anything you have antibodies against is going to be destroyed.
So, you have to be sleeping. It's a huge component.
Again, adaptogens can be very beneficial for this.
CBD can be very beneficial. NTHC can be very beneficial to calm the brain.
There's a lot of different herb blends. I like it.
It's subnetal is one of my favorite but there's different herb blends that can help you calm down and sleep.
If you have to use melatonin or anything like that, highly advise you use that to try to get some sleep.
Don't overlook screen time.
If you're looking at screens, I'm looking at my computer right now doing this.
My computer screen is a frequency of 60 hertz.
You know, that's a super, super high beta wave.
So, my brain is firing at 60 hertz. Watch out the screen.
So, you're looking at your phone at night before you go to bed.
You're firing your brain at 60 hertz and you have to get down to a theta wave to go to sleep.
That's down to 7 to 11 hertz.
Your brain has to drop that down to that frequency in order for you to sleep.
So, consider reducing screen time at the end of the day.
That can be helpful to help your brain calm down and go to sleep.
And then exercise.
So, exercise is the last component I really want to talk about with lifestyle.
Over exercising can be as bad as under exercising.
Keep that in mind.
If you're birding the candle at two ends, put me in 10,000 steps a day.
Don't think that you should be exercising also.
So, but a lot of people are sedentary.
That's not good either.
So, hints on exercise.
You need to take simple steps if you are sedentary.
You need to find something that you enjoy doing.
You know, if you're like, I'm going to do this because I have to exercise.
It's not going to be something you continue.
So, just be honest with yourself.
And if you love gardening, that's my wife and I love to do.
Or outside all the time in the summertime.
We're working on the garden, working on the yard.
We take a lot of joy in that.
Find something you take joy in.
Do in different seasons.
And that can get you your daily exercise.
Again, this is all part of the detangling of autoimmune disease.
And we're going to continue to study and continue to give you information
so you can work through these things.
Know that I pray for you.
And for your education and for your understanding that God gives you insights and all things.
Thanks.